31 magnet schools within ccsd are  accepting applications for the next  school year magnet schools focus on  socialized subjects such as stem  performing arts and communication joe  mackey is the only k-8 magnet school in  the district students there learn about  digital sciences leadership and global  communication through hands-on  activities when students are interested  in what they're learning when they have  a reason to go to school  that keeps them there that engages them  in what they're learning they're able to  apply what they're learning to  experiences in the real world  ccsd is hosting multiple in-person and  virtual parent workshops to learn about  the variety of programs a magnet choice  fair will be held on november 6 with all  schools in attendance